[Musique]
nous sommes le 3 novembre 2016 bienvenue
pour cette dernière édition de la
semaine du 7 8 et les invités rencontres
avec celles et ceux qui font l'actualité
dans le département et aujourd'hui vous
entendrez sonia pour hausser la
responsable de la cgt des yvelines nous
reviendrons sur le climat social actuel
un climat tendu à quelques mois de
l'élection présidentielle
le syndicat entend t-il joué un rôle
dans cette campagne et puis elle
jean-philippe plus il est adjoint au
maire de bois d'arcy en charge de la
culture il nous présentera la deuxième
édition du festival de la bande annonce
qui se déroule ce week-end
pour débuter nous revenons donc sur ce
climat social tendu actuellement dans le
pays actions des salariés de la poste
par exemple inquiets de la
réorganisation prochaine de leur travail
manifestation le 8 novembre des
infirmières une profession qui se
déclarent en souffrance les policiers
qui eux aussi battre le pavé depuis
plusieurs semaines de nombreux corps de
métiers expriment leur mal être et je
reçois donc ce soir sonia porot la
responsable cgt dans les yvelines elle
les syndicats qui s'impliquent
régulièrement aux côtés des salariés
c'est le cas de votre à syndicats
bonsoir à l'entrée un petit peu dans les
détails à quelques mois de ses élections
présidentielles puis législatives
est ce que finalement toute cette
agitation des salariés n'est pas normal
parce qu'on rentre dans une période de
campagne et tout le monde a aussi envie
d'un peu d'attention et aussi qu'on
s'occupe un petit peu d'eux je pense que
la mobilisation et les revendications
nombreux zinc exprimés les salariés
aujourd'hui ne sont pas que liés
à la proximité d'une élection mais bien
à des phénomènes de fond sur plusieurs
années notamment les sous-effectifs les
réductions d'emplois notamment dans la
fonction publique les réorganisations
permanentes qui font qu'aujourd'hui les
salariés expriment leur ras-le-bol
est-ce que vous aujourd'hui à la cgt
vous êtes dans un combat politique très
clairement vous voulez poser pendant
cette campagne est la cgt bien sûr veut
peser dans l'est dans les débats
politiques pas au sens partisan ou
politiciens du terme mais bien sûr les
propositions des candidats sur les
aspects socio-économiques ont des
impacts sur les salariés sur les
retraités sur les jeunes qui vont entrer
dans la vie active donc ce que proposent
les candidats bien sûr qu'on le regarde
par rapport à nos revendications aux
besoins des salariés vous avez le
sentiment qu'aujourd'hui les la
dimension sociale est plutôt absente des
débats qui sont organisés autour des
potentiels candidats ce soir doit se
tenir du deuxième débat juste en éclats
de l'est républicain et du centre pour 7
pour cette primaire le sentiment qu'on
oublie le social
clairement c'est pas effectivement la
priorité alors que les préoccupations de
la population elles sont sur l'emploi
sur les conditions de travail sur les
niveaux de salaire sur la précarité et
ça on n'en parle pas assez
mais justement les salariés comme vous
le disiez se mobilisent très
régulièrement pour se faire entendre
quelles sont les situations aujourd'hui
donc département des yvelines qui vous
préoccupe plus particulièrement ce cas
les secteurs des domaines j'ai évoqué la
poste par exemple j'ai évoqué les
infirmières même s'ils sont des
mouvements nationaux ça touche aussi le
départ a bien sûr puisque même sans
attendre les journées d'actions prévues
nationalement il ya déjà des
mobilisations locales les salariés des
hôpitaux par exemple étaient déjà
mobilisés avant l'été se sont rassemblés
à versailles donc il ya déjà des
mobilisations
on a par exemple une très belle
mobilisation pour la sauvegarde du
bureau de poste de plaisir gars avec une
très forte implication des habitants et
des usagers qui est vraiment
intéressante et dans plein d'entreprises
il ya des mouvements sur les conditions
de travail et les salaires on vous a vu
aussi récemment aux côtés des
travailleurs sans papiers dans un
conflit qui les opposait notamment
sodexo où on est ce conflit alors on a
pu trouver un accord avec l'entreprise
sur le processus de régularisation
puisque la cgt se bat pour faire
reconnaître le travail de tous les
salariés y compris de ceux qui sont sans
papiers c'est un combat qui est très
très fort dans la cgt puisque quand on
renforce les droits des plus précaires
les travailleurs sans papiers les
travailleurs détachés voilà les
contractuels dans la fonction publique
où les intérimaires on renforce les
droits de l'ensemble des salariés donc
c'est vraiment un combat important pour
tout le monde salariés largement sur la
situation sociale aujourd'hui en france
la cassure avec le gouvernement elle se
situe ou sur ces dernières années c'est
la loi travail c'est la loi travail
c'est d'autre loivre c'est la loi macron
c'est la loi rebsamen ce sont des lois
voilà qui flexibilise le notamment le
temps de travail la loi macron c'est
aussi
la facilité du travail du dimanche que
refusent les salariés et ceux qui
l'acceptent c'est pour des questions de
salaires d'insuffisante plus que parce
qu'ils veulent travailler le dimanche
quand on a le choix salariés qui
expliquent dans leur organisation
personnelle ça peut aussi les satisfaire
de travailler le dimanche oui bien sûr
c'est par exemple le cas des jeunes et
des étudiants qui qui ont besoin
effectivement de deux gagnent leur vie
en parallèle de leurs études mais là
dessus on a des propositions
alternatives
par exemple d'augmenter les bourses et
d'offrir
de quoi de quoi vivre aux étudiants pour
qu'ils puissent se consacrer à leurs
études
c'est une des revendications de la cgt
et c'est d'ailleurs une des victoires du
mouvement contre la loi travail d'avoir
permis des avancées pour les jeunes et
le maintien de la bourse par exemple sur
l'entrée du marché du travail si la cgt
avait un candidat ce serait jean luc
mélenchon non si la cgt n'a pas de n'a
pas de candidat la cgt elle a des
revendications et l regard de ce que
propose est partie elle donne son avis
sur des propositions pas sur des
candidats on n'a pas de candidat ou
d'appels pour untel ou untel j'aimerais
juste qu'on termine cet entretien parle
par une autre élection qui peut être
moins médiatisé mais néanmoins
importante sélection les élections
syndicale dans les tpe les très petites
entreprises de moins de onze salariés 3
millions 5,2 salariés qui travaillent
dans ces petites entreprises de moins de
onze salariés vont devoir élire leurs
représentants syndicaux qui vont
négocier ensuite les conventions les
accords collectifs au niveau des
branches professionnelles notamment
comment vous abordez ce scrutin qui a
par le passé il ya eu un précédent
c'était en 2012 avait assez peu mobilisé
la participation était de seulement 10
points 4 bon sang c'est une
revendication forte de la cgt que tous
les salariés puissent avoir des
représentants pour défendre leurs
revendications
et cette année c'est la première fois
qu'il y aura des représentants choisis
par les salariés des très petites
entreprises dans des commissions
régionales donc ça donne un aspect plus
concret à l'élection effectivement c'est
des salariés qui sont forcément très
très dispersé et contacts dans par des
distributions de tracts par des
courriers par des réunions publiques en
fonction des professions on en organise
pour la construction pour les salariés
des hôtels cafés restaurants ou pour les
salariés du particulier employeur comme
les assistantes maternelles mais pour
les syndicats et pour la cgt mais pour
les autres aussi c'est important parce
que il en va de votre représentativité
c'est souvent ce qu'on a entendu aussi
dans les différents arguments dans les
combats et les débats politiques qui
sont menées c'est que les syndicats que
sur la cgt autres ne sont pas assez
aussi quelquefois représentatif
lorsqu'on le voit qu'il y a dix pour
cent et quelques de votants à une
élection de représentation syndicale
on se pose la question donc il ya un
enjeu particulier pour vous aussi de
l'enjeu c'est bien sûr de rassembler les
salles arie de pouvoir défendre les
revendications par rapport à ce que
vivent les salariés selon les différents
types d'entreprises ou les différents
secteurs de métiers donc évidemment
c'est l'occasion d'inviter ses salariés
la à rejoindre la cgt à faire leurs
syndicats puisque la cgt c'est d'abord
les salariés qui décident d'adhérer qui
font ce qu est la cgt en 2012 on a pu
créer le syndicat des assistantes
maternelles qui va s'agrandir pour
accueillir tous les salariés du
particulier employeur et je pense qu'on
arrivera à créer d'autres syndicats avec
les salariés des tpe qui voudront bien
nous rejoindre l'élection dont les tpe
se déroule du 28 novembre au 12 décembre
prochain aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
vous sentez justement une organisation
représentative des salariés
pas pas suffisamment bien sûr il ya
toujours des progrès à faire parce que
le monde du travail évolue avec la sous
traitance avec de plus en plus d'emplois
hautement qualifiés donc on cherche
toujours évidemment à mieux coller au
salariat par par nos initiatives par nos
distributions de tracts c'est des choses
qu'on travaille bien sûr et on se remet
régulièrement en question sur nos
manières de faire de communiquer et
d'être le plus à l'écouté des salariés
de ce qu'ils ont à dire sur leur travail
donc je le rappelle vous participer à ce
scrutin comme d'autres syndicats l'avoir
présenté aujourd'hui la cgt mais il y en
ad'autres un saut pour lesquels bien
évidemment les différents salariés
peuvent voter et et s'exprimer ce sera à
partir du 28 novembre
une fois ces élections passées il y aura
en parlait au début de cet entretien ses
différentes campagnes présidentielles
législatives
dernière question vous avez prévu
d'interpeller aussi les différents
candidats sur le plan local aux
législatives par exemple on en est pas
encore là puisque on est vraiment dans
déjà des mobilisations très importante
de salariés sur sur leurs revendications
concrètes mais c'est effectivement une
possibilité qu'on étudiera merci sonia
porot d'être venu en plateau responsable
cgt dans le département des yvelines est
cinéma à présent avec le festival de la
bande annonce est à bois d'arcy la
deuxième édition a lieu ce week end
c'est un festival pour découvrir ces
courtes oeuvres parfois insolites
parfois même bien meilleur est un bien
meilleur à niveau que les longs métrages
eux-mêmes présentation de ce rendez vous
avec jean philippe plus c'est le maire
adjoint en charge de la culture
dans cette commune et c'est au micro de
mélanie poker pour la deuxième année
consécutive donc la ville de bois d'arcy
va accueillir le festival de la bande
annonce à voir si le fameux festival b à
ba donc c'est un événement qui a
rencontré un franc succès l'année
dernière donc nous n'avons évidemment
reconduit lors duquel vincent perrot
donc l'animateur de la soirée par un 2 2
du festival viendra présenter et
échanger avec le public sur différentes
thématiques et différentes
bandes-annonces comme la saison dernière
ça avait très bien fonctionné c'est
totalement original c'est le seul
festival dédié sur ce thème en france
pourquoi la bande-annonce pas parce que
la bande annonce c'est le premier point
d'entrée d'un spectateur d'un est ainsi
née cinéphile pour aller au cinéma c'est
la première chose qu'ils voient ça peut
donner envie comme ça peut rebuter
d'ailleurs donc c'est un sit-in à sanaa
à part entière c'est vraiment ça peut
donner envie
et c'est tout un travail de pouvoir l'a
constitué et la faire le mieux possible
pour que les gens y adonnent est en vie
et que la seule bande annonce donne
envie d'aller au cinéma il va voir des
thématiques autour du western notamment
où la comédie est toujours est toujours
on y tient d'ailleurs des nouveautés des
bandes annonces en exclusivité pour
donner envie aux arcisien et aux gens
qui vont venir à ce festival de d'aller
au cinéma tout le monde aime prochain
pour retrouver les changer un certain
savoir faire au nom qu à vous mais ne
riez retrouver ma famille je n'avais
jamais rendu sa liberté à quelqu'un
je me sens responsable de toi
destination calvin candie
le propriétaire de go die hard
l'objectif justement être pas faire un
festival trop cinéphiles et justement
ouvert au grand public donc qui aura
notamment une des premières bandes
annonces officielles qui date des années
1920 en partenariat avec le cnc mais il
y aura aussi des films récents mois
récents connus ou moins connus du grand
public l'objectif étant de seulement 2
de faire partager les connaissances de
vincent perrot et faire une soirée
intéressante autour de sa bande annonce
donc des bains-douches connu comme moins
connus
et
l'année dernière donc on lançait du
festival la bande annonce cette année on
fait un déploiement complémentaires
puisqu'on va le dimanche faire une
session juniors donc le béaba junior à
partir de 16 heures l'objectif étant de
donner envie aux jeunes et aux moins
jeunes puisqu'ils vont être pour la
plupart accompagnés de leurs parents
voire grands parents de venir au cinéma
et découvrir les bandes annonces par là
la thématique est un peu différente
puisque l'objectif est de montrer aux
enfants et aux jeunes publics les bandes
annonces des films qui vont sortir tout
au long de l'année prochaine c'est la
fin du set suite les invités pour ce
soir et pour cette semaine dès vendredi
vous avez rendez vous avec nikola
kirillovitch pour le 7 8 l hebdo en
attendant les programmes se poursuivre
sur notre antenne
[Musique]